[Musique]
ça nous donne envie de rire tuerie on se
moque de lui on se cache un peu parce
que si c'était nous on n'aimerait pas
concentré de nous et pourquoi ça fait
rire de voir parce que qu'est-ce qu'on
imagine on imagine des choses sa tête
oui je suis sûr qu'il en soit d'accord
et c'est une maladie d'être trop je
crois que c'est la première question à
poser évidemment parce que il difficile
d'appeler maladie cet état qui
finalement n'amène pas de troubles au
moins immédiat une amène un certain
malaise peut être un malaise social
un malaise psychologique mais c'est
difficile de parler de maladies par
carole gras je tue et dalila et ups
combien c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
trop
70 kg et tu avais plus oui j'ai fait 80
kilos pour 1 mètre
c'était trop là à pourquoi est ce que tu
dis ici à herriot parce que j'ai des
problèmes de poids que ma mère me trouve
un second a préféré on est à fois il ya
qu'il ya quelque chose d'ordinaire parce
que t'es trop gourmande n'ont même pas
ces périodes moi je crois qu'il sait
jusqu au système est ce qu'on dit c'est
pas alors mais non ma pharmacie stopper
mon fond d'écran dire comment on fait
honte et y supprimer les collèges de
suivre ça me deux mois une calorie
ça me permet de stabiliser mon point de
grandir
qu'est ce que tu veux tu es tu as d'être
un petit peu trop aux noix et indirects
mais les élèves qui sont dans les autres
classes parce que il se moque un peu de
nos 80 euros est ce que tes copines te
dis donc tu es un petit peu fort
ils sont comme toi
on était amoureux qu'est ce qui dit je
n'ai pas qu'est ce qui te disais alors à
l'école les copains avant d'égréner
jeunes gens se moquent de toi à l'école
qu'est ce qu'on te dit
qu'est ce que les autres sont méchants
avec toi tu es très copines et là qui
sont un petit peu forte si comme ça tu
aimes bien mais les gens comme toi mais
pourquoi tu es devenu battue a toujours
été un beau bébé
c'est comme si on disait tout le temps
il faut que j'y vois aussi ce que
j'étais trop mail puis on n'est plus à
manger que les autres
puis à force ça c'est pas un peu
difficile en cours de gymnastique de
courir peut-être un peu moins vite que
les autres du conte aussi vite tu sont
aussi haut
[Musique]
chez toi on essayait de interdire de
manger ou de faire un régime non non moi
je me disais moi même faire attention à
manger sainement
qu'est ce que tu faisais tu achetais tu
achètes des caramels en cachette ou des
noms des banques achètent carrément moi
mais je sais que c'est mort a carrément
fait cependant interdit de manger et une
lance pas de chocolat
ça me donne les mêmes à comment tu fais
là
et tu te sers jamais tout seul tu vas
jamais dans le placard en a c'est sa
ceinture blanche beaucoup à ce moment là
ce qui est dingue c'est quoi parce que
dans tous les sens et sont mal nourris
les enfants trop gros subissent les
conséquences de cette
novès de façon de se nourrir d'une façon
plus visible que les lire mais c'est
vrai que des enfants qui mangent trop de
sucre qui salle trop les plats qui mange
trop de viande oeufs
peut-être ne vont pas grossir mais ils
prennent un certain nombre ça non je
connais pas ça c'est du potiron confie
cuit h avec beaucoup beurre et du
gruyère
bon donc pour la ville s'était pas tant
a quand même se pose pas les problèmes
avec la mode
6 à l'époque ça l'est pas en quel genre
d'avis de quoi parle d'un poulet mambé
ministre bon je ne pose pas de problème
un petit peu je peux pas donner un
billet quand j'ai une amie à la mode
parce que vous les jupes sont trop
longues ou ya ne savons pas où ça ne va
pas alors maigri on cherche jamais à
faire maigrir un enfant période de
croissance
je pense que c'est un effort trop
important et qui est en général
responsable des chèques l'enfant fait un
effort trop considérable pendant
quelques semaines
et cet effort en train de chez lui un
rejet des conseils qui ont été données
et il reprend du poids encore plus vite
qu il l'a perdu alors ce qu'on cherche à
faire c'est que halo simone cet enfant
ne grossissent pas pendant que sa
croissance se poursuit et au moins que
la croissance en bois fois plus faible
plus lente que la croissance en tag
chansons et puis bon bah je vais pas
essayer de remédier à 10 ans par là et
j'ai maigri des kilos mais en très peu
de temps alors c'est au mouvement j'aime
d'elie que c'était plus tristement est
alors pourquoi tu as repris ce 10 kilos
non parce que je me suis laissé aller
puis à 10 ans
et toi tu te trouve bien comme ça tu as
envie de maigrir un peu et pourquoi
maigrir pour pouvoir courir plus vite
non ça se voit pas vraiment demain tu
commences ta maman tu surveilles sur le
plan alimentaire
quels sont les rapports entre vous tous
qui est jeanne alimentaire
oui parce que bon je pense que tous les
enfants qui en sont les problèmes de
boulimie n'accepte pas qu'on leur dise
travail et ne mange pas su lee ne mange
pas ça j'en ai parlé puisque je suis un
petit peu troublé par ce phénomène j'en
ai parlé avec mon médecin qui m'a dit
que c'était une erreur fondamentale que
c'est du trois quarts des parents c'est
de dire aux enfants ne mangent pas ça ne
mange pas si c'est le font exprès pour
pour changer un petit peu et je me suis
rendu compte que l'état de médias ça
tout le temps elle faisait exprès de
reprendre des plats ou de manger en
cachette
et vous oui parce que je pense que bon
moi je gens souffrent aussi du fait
qu'elle soit un peu forte je me rends
compte par rapport à ses camarades que
j'ai des poèmes d'habillement des choses
comme ça à côté de cela elle est
tellement bien dans sa peau il est
difficile de faire une part des choses
non ça c'est pour elle quoi c'est pour
son avenir je ne voudrais pas que
j'allais des problèmes de boulimie plus
tard est ce que vous vous suivez un
régime par exemple pour essayer de lui
faire manger la même chose oui oui oui
effectivement en disant bon là j'ai des
problèmes parce que je travaille
toute la semaine on marié également donc
elle mange très souvent à la cantine
donc il est très difficile de lui faire
faire un régime et lorsque je peux
l'avoir avec moi ont des grillades et
salades des yaourts enfin beaucoup de
crédibilité des trucs comme ça
j'essaye d'équilibré et surtout le soir
lorsqu'on se retrouve à manger alors à
part les conseils qui vous a donné le
médecin qu'est ce que le médecin lui a
dit non je vivais à dimanche c'est ton
problème c'est pas ça les deux premières
et alors ça lui a fait plaisir on n'a
pas du tout elle s'en fiche complètement
elle a dit moi je suis bien dans ma peau
est alors dans l ael à 12 heures est-ce
que vous pensez que ça va ça va changer
oui en rapport avec les autres disent
oui j'ai ressenti un petit peu une
évolution dans le sens où vont elles
commencent à s'intéresser à tout ce qui
m'entoure notamment notamment bon le
sexe opposé et je pense que c'est là où
on va pouvoir trouver la faille pour
qu'elle fasse elle d'elle même elle
commence à dire non mais je veux pas
manger ça parce qu'il faut que je
maigrisse d'aller chez le coiffeur en
disant que je m'arrange parce que j'ai
la bouillante pendant je pense qu'on va
pouvoir trouver donc s'appelle qui va
faire le trajet tout seul je crois mais
je conseille ce qui est important en
fait parce que bon nous on est là pour
l'aider
[Musique]